things are out is that a real phone or
is that fake those are real
those are real those are real
I see why you guys need more women on
this show no talking about the feet
those are real
[Music]
and we got another one of Nick's
favorites in the lineup to talk about
today is the hospital it's not Hospital
nor is it prince Andrew but it's
connected
jizz Lane Maxwell another one of your
favorites I see the way your smile just
kind of curls just light up like a
Christmas are you team galane Maxwell
like in what way I don't know just
overall support
team security guard team security guard
I think I just I just want to see her
win you know
imagine hey imagine
I just want to see her like get Justin
get her business back on time do you
think there's a way that she can lose
the case against her but still win in
another aspect you know honestly if if
I'm being frank I haven't really been
following it since uh well they don't
even cover it though yeah like I just
you know I just haven't really paid
attention to it but I feel like she's
gonna something's gonna happen what do
you think is gonna happen I think she's
gonna get away
like physically get away maybe not
physically but I feel like because the
last time we covered her
her case got dismissed right
no she was trying to appeal it with the
jury thing the juror but it didn't go
through it didn't go through okay so
she's still behind bars so she's still
behind bars and she has recently just
claimed that a woman plotted to kill her
behind bars as she serves a 20-year
sentence for committing sex crimes
against children she's [ __ ] loophole
Queen man yeah because it's like for me
I'm like who gives a [ __ ] who she is who
the [ __ ] did you traffic to your Island
right like let's see the list they're
not even focusing on on that thing you
know they're just focusing on just her
I'm like she doesn't really matter do
you think her claim might be credible
considering like her partner Epstein was
you know
all cameras turned off all security
guards are going at the exact same
moment and then some [ __ ] happened do
you think that she actually has a kind
of a credible claim to the possibility
that somebody also might try to
nope I think she people in her position
of power
the chances are she's uh one step ahead
of the law versus the laws that step
ahead of her see that's the thing it's
like I'm really starting to believe that
both of them were part of like
intelligence like they were planted
there to be doing this kind of stuff to
get leverage on people
wow okay I see what you're saying
because there's a lot of like um
and you know take this with a grain of
salt because we're obviously what can
doesn't like salt there's no salt in
this fries like I'm obviously not an
expert Bart's probably more of an expert
in the field than the PHD in it but like
when you hear certain people talk about
it who are like former FBI people or
whatever they go it's probably most
likely that
Epstein and just Lane with the J
that they were that they were part of
intelligence either Mossad right or FBI
or CIA who knows they just don't know
but they based on people that work in
that field they're like it's probably
more likely that that's the case but but
that means it was an approved concept of
intelligence that would allow the use of
children like pedophilia you think that
they would go that far you think that's
above the US government they've done
crazier [ __ ] why are you laughing Ryan
it's a serious conversation about our
country whether whether I think any
government agency that has some some
stature and that has um
you know things to gain that means a lot
to them I think they would do stuff like
that when they say when they call
something Black Ops that's that that's
the reason it's like anything goes like
Ambu Black Ops means anything goes whoa
you know I mean like anything the
craziest thing what's the crazy thing to
think of that's amble Black Ops why are
you trying to make me nervous
yeah it's crazy he put on your shirt
boss you're harassing us such Snips are
Out Boy but they've done things um not
Operation Paperclip but some other one
where they're like you know in order for
us to like warn ourselves uh to invade
Cube or start a war with Cuba they were
going to paint
um
paint one of their ships and and then
have a cruise liner on our side they
just have to be casualties and just blow
it up yeah and anger basically framed
them yeah yeah I killed our own people
so that our own people are down to go
just to ignite the whole thing yeah
pretty normal and that this is actually
a Declassified information now you can
see it on Wikipedia it's like yeah it's
it's in line with history yeah that's
how that's how America was able to
attain the Mexican land
you know about that what happened Texas
and they got California
how do they take them into it with David
Jones wrote some treaty they wrote some
World treaty where they're like all
right once America expanded to the
border of where um Texas was divided
they were like all right we're not gonna
[ __ ] take any more land from you guys
we've agreed to not fight it's fine
unless you guys start [ __ ] then we're
gonna invade invade and Mexico's like
we're not We're not gonna [ __ ] invade
we're all just gonna live it's gonna be
fine and then they pushed it where they
uh America and the the guy was president
at the time they put this plan in motion
where they basically made it look like
they were gonna [ __ ] do it for so
long that eventually Mexico crossed over
and broke that treaty and then as soon
as that happened everything was in place
to take it all over and the motivation
was to claim the gold that was in the
mountains at
um the Mexicans couldn't mine whoa so
once that Gold Rush happened it was
because it was over the land that now
belonged to America and it was [ __ ]
crazy I feel like they do that all the
time so what do you think in this uh
jizzlin with the J and two Z's uh
situation what do you think
someone had to gain is it just Leverage
is it you know what I'm saying I know
we're speculating for entertaining his
hypothesis yeah we're entertaining the
hypothesis why is it just mine we're not
idiots it's not just my hypothesis even
though this is the truth the one and
only truth given to you now exclusively
from just kidding news specifically by
Bert Swann and Joe at 2 20 p.m you know
what it also could be American work
culture where it's like I don't [ __ ]
care you do it just get it done so maybe
his [ __ ] guy he was like he was doing
what
like he was horrified he was just
getting down he's like you get me
leverage and you get me results no but
it's like but you hired Jeffrey Epstein
post chocolate I've never reviewed a
single performance sheet
we had no metrics dude they just let him
go he's like you weren't complaining
when it was working honestly I wouldn't
be surprised dude yeah that's crazy but
what was the question again sorry just
like what would be a hypothetical like
is it just Leverage is it trying to you
know kind of pretty much put people into
kind of a blackmailing situation and
there were other higher authorities that
are response like ambassadors to other
nations and or what like I think they're
trying to get to that Crown baby
they trying to get to that British crown
and they try to do it through my boy
prince Andrew there's just like here's 3
000 years of Revenge or whatever or 300
years yeah I don't know I I think I
think they're just trying to incriminate
people and maybe blackmailed people I
don't know to what extent that's I'm not
smart enough this is your hypothesis we
gotta you gotta be the fact and the
foundation for us to be able to to riff
as Jason would say
Bart do you want to be that guy
can I can I pass it on to Bart no why
are you talking to me like that
cannot speak English that's so nice oh
that's so nice
hey you know what you know what it is
too I highly doubt that everything that
um Epstein got in trouble for and Glenn
I highly doubt that's even the main
thing that they were trying to do I
don't think this prostitution thing was
even the number one Money Maker game
changer whatever because like every it's
just like surface level [ __ ] exactly
because every historical arrest of major
criminals they got them on the thing
they
or something right yeah it's like
they're just getting them on what they
can get them on because what they're
really doing they can't get them on it
so whatever the [ __ ] that is let's worry
about this [ __ ] other [ __ ] as much as
possible because if you don't uncover
that and you never touch that that might
still be alive somewhere yeah and just
ran by another person yeah God damn dude
damn
it's better your own hypothesis well
Ryan's way smarter that's why he's the
host
oh he's a host come over there
so everybody knows this Infamous photo
is all right I don't remember who that's
your boy dude that is your boy remember
who that is dude he doesn't remember
that picture being taken okay wait she's
in uh elf right
is that her no that's not her dude yeah
that's her Zoey Deschanel
no she's uh no she's not the one in elf
Fargo is that du Freight uh who's that
dude that's prince Andrew this is
different that's that's jizzling with
the twozies in a j that's prince Andrew
and she drizzling is now claiming very
very very very very confidently that
this is a fake photo it kind of it kind
of looks very what do you think looks
fake her in the background
dude why her eyes like that
because it's fake obviously why is that
a fake photo did she say what exactly
about it is fake uh because if she can't
point that out no she didn't she just
says quote at this time I no longer
believe that to be a true image and I
don't believe that it is what it appears
to be
because she used to say it was real she
said it was probably real back in the
day she said there are so many things
that are wrong with it as soon as my
appeal is over I will be very happy to
discuss it with you why don't we [ __ ]
blowtorch her fingers and just ask her
for the truth thank you keep it
let's keep it simple yeah keep it real
grassy she's just playing all these
[ __ ] games because she's just all she
has to do every single time is evidence
well that's not true and everyone's like
oh it's not true in that picture
so she's stalling yeah it's just
misdirection it's her version of goal oh
what's that and everyone's like oh yeah
everyone's a sucker yeah that's my
appeal because even I did I was wrong
plus it's like she it's like everything
she says is leverage based she can't
just be like oh it's this 50 things that
are wrong with that thing I don't know
that's crazy I'm not gonna play where's
Waldo with that picture what's wrong
with this phone what's wrong with this
photo
is that her that's her who is that
Epstein on the side is Epstein oh she's
doing a foot massage doing a little foot
massage oh with their titties though
with their boobies oh things are out is
that a real photo is that fake those are
real
those are real those are real
I'm just talking about the feet
and why you guys need more women on this
show no talking about the feet those are
real
[Laughter]
I just mean like sometimes they pixelate
people's feets out yeah and then those
are real those are real
funny where are his toes
but yeah like Epstein is dead I think it
doesn't even matter yeah who cares dude
you think Elaine's gonna die I don't
think she's gonna die there's a whole
book of names okay let's throw it away
The Ledger hey those are real dude yeah
I just don't even know what's gonna
happen next I just I have no idea I
think at this point whatever role she
played in whatever scheme they're
running I think she's Beyond you
know
yeah
that's a craziest most sophisticated
disc I've ever heard you are so hot I
think once the narrative starts going
every which way it's because whoever was
controlling it let go and said take it
it doesn't [ __ ] matter because now
it's up to the public now too now
everyone's just making it about this and
that and this and that it's a wild card
now because it's inconsequential she's
like disposable yeah it's like okay you
know she'll be the lab it's fine yeah I
think they both are huh you think it'd
be easier to get rid of the Lamb or to
just let the lamb keep on anywhere I
mean do you think two people could
really run that operation it's gonna be
gone after they're in jail no way
[ __ ] it takes nine people to run to
[ __ ] June B
that's true at least nine speaking of
jimbie they're opening up in Waikiki
this is the sponsored video
guava coming soon
not spelled with a J yeah jizzby
[Music]
thank you